[Applause]
y'all look
fabulous oh my go you look fabulous yes
you look fabulous um so how long have
y'all been in New York I just got here I
love it oh yeah how long you're born and
raised born and raised yeah never could
leave I tried a few times but yeah
myself back yeah yeah I've been here for
a while I'm telling you everyone comes
to New York for six months and then they
never leave yeah yeah it's pretty great
better to stay yeah it is pretty great
and I I'm a total Southern so I never
thought I'd say that but I actually love
it and like whereever you live is kind
of your own little small village like
your own small town like of stuff I love
true and people are like well this area
is better and I like this one more and
they're great yeah but why why do you
choose to do the show do you feel like
it's exciting to do that or do you do
you get a little nervous being a part of
a show like this because everybody's in
your life I don't think we knew what we
were getting into oh that's that's how
they got you yeah I took a job yeah I
thought it was
she's a model I was like yep I'll do it
I was like you know it's just another
job but I really didn't know what I was
sign up it's really not like it's real
life uh but it's good because we learn a
lot about each other and learn about
ourselves and I don't know I think it's
it's a good uh platform for women right
we get our own business we get to say
what we want to say I think our
relationship might kind of help other
people other girls so for that I think
it has you know benefit to it and I mean
I also feel like I come from a culture
that is really private women can talk
like you know the whole thing so me
being in New York and be getting this
kind of opportunity I'm like I should
not not take it I think it's just it's
great like having as a woman having a
platform solid Point I've never really
thought about that not many women in all
over the world get to have that choice
to get what we get to do like it's it's
it's an amazing and and I think also
like we're all girls girls most of us at
least and I think we there's so much
there with what you just said sorry
whoops she she's a coner she just can
help it you know what though it's really
entertaining no but you know it's like a
Sisterhood that we've all formed and
it's unbreakable because we've no one
else will understand what we all went
through together you know what I mean I
feel like they threw eyes in like
seretti at night and figure out how to
get out yeah and she was just like
listen I I not you my your cup of tea
but you're going to help me get out of
here yeah so it's like we are the only
people can really understand what is
happening and what's going on and it it
it keeps us closer but also being close
with someone that also can bring a lot
of yeah the closeness actually can turn
on you because you get so close you're
like why did you do that to me you get
hurt more yeah yeah which is just
happens in friendship in a way that like
you are so close to me you should know
right so it's like no sometime you just
have to communicate and that goes across
everyone in this world like people don't
a lot of husband and wife are fighting
for this like he should just know we've
been together for so long that's a good
point like he's not he's not God he
doesn't you have to really articulate
your feelings for people you know and
you be very clear and don't do it when
you're angry because then nobody can
hear it oh I'm the person I have to I I
have to gooo I need a minute I'm going
to be on my own I can't do it like right
in the moment which bothers people I
know because boundaries yeah well it
bothers people because they don't want
they're like no we need to remedy it
right now and I'm like I know but I'm
not in a good freedom of mind so you
have to respect that part yeah did you
were you like or you learn oh lots of
therapy Uber
yes like lots of therapy yes I was not
into confrontation going into therapist
I think therapy is like a privilege like
if you it is a priv like you know what a
lucky thing God I grew up around people
being like go R about it or something
nobody cares like you know what I'm
saying like it's like when you're poor
nobody has that luxury you know such a
luxury but to have a trained
professional go hey this is maybe how
you should navigate this or whatever but
yeah knowing how to hey I don't deal
well in that situation it's like to walk
away for a minute but I guess the
producers on your show are like don't
walk away don't walk away sit in it
actually I did some walking honestly
they don't tell us oh you can do
whatever you want to do I can close the
door and go to sleep I can take this out
if I want to they will film you but they
don't tell you why to do oh I like the
power in that though this is coming off
this is yeah but but you are so in the
heat you don't want to once you're in
the mess you're like I'm already in a
mess anyways let's do
this I love you so well this is the
first time in Real Housewives history
that the show recast an entire city so
we had uba and aon's castmate Jenna
Lions on the show a few weeks back and
she had this to say about the new season
I think what's nice about this season is
that everyone has somebody different to
kind of plug into we're all pretty
different like
much more diverse I think between age
and ethnicity and background and age I'm
the old one yeah she does not look old
I'm like what do you agree with that
though like the new season having better
representation just across the board
absolutely I think even in term of
geographic like where we live even where
we live is different yeah I think we're
really it's such a different thing such
a different I don't even they kind of
had to do if you're going to completely
you know do a rehaul of it and have new
I think that's cooler yeah no yeah it's
really not the same you mean even our
professions like they're all so
different we don't all do the same thing
I know I want to get into that I'm going
to get into that so yall had Conflict at
one point right but you're good now well
you seem good now or you're either
really good actors are we good actors
yeah horrible I swear to God we will not
do that to you guys to come I you I I'm
not I don't do fake no me neither oh my
God gets me in
trouble it's exhausting to have to
protect I think that's something I need
to learn going forward like being in the
public eye sometime you can't say
everything you mean yeah because I would
like to be more fake yeah it's just
difficult yeah yeah yeah I think
um our our fight was very real yeah and
it was huge
misunderstanding in a both side um and
unfortunately none of you guys will ever
see the all six hours of filming of that
oh you CU know they cannot show you guys
everything so they show what they want
to show and let's face it if they don't
leave you guys question or calling one
of us is bad or is not then what's going
to bring him back to what is there's no
next season right yeah so I end I am
learning that prod accept it I'm
learning trust me very insightful I know
I was like that's more like how a produc
hard ble no because what's you're very
uh private with like your personal life
and you're pretty open right I'm way too
open and my husband is way too open I'm
like we're not going to talk about
everything next time because yeah what
has been shown is our entire sex life
great hey but that's not a problem
congratulations congratulations
hysterical no one has ever said that
yeah well not everybody's having that
life right now um so you're you're back
to you so you're you're very private
about it though right you're like so
here's the thing I'm not private I have
never been private of my relationship I
love to flaunt my mens I love it yeah
cuz I usually get them Hot smart and
Rich oh yeah all
right I mean yeah I love it yeah you
know women wear jewelry and we usually
have you are what you extended of the
person next to you right yeah this is
why I tell guys I'm like I don't know
why they are so afraid of getting
married you literally getting a build-in
coner your wife is like 24 hours coner
no opposite no he's my coner well for
you in your relationship but most women
they're the one who taking care of their
wife what to wear what to eat mared men
have a better life div yeah than single
no I'm with you how is speaking of
family though how is your mom doing
she's health concerns right now right
yes so I I haven't really said this
anywhere and I don't want to get choked
up I'm she's okay with me talking about
it but she had breast cancer this summer
yeah um that's hard and it's hard
because she's like my strong family
member like my healthy strong nothing
ever happens to her so it really threw
me for a loop and it was just a lot but
thank God I mean the the the amount of
change that's happened in this world I
mean in terms of health and yeah I'm
like I get choked up so I start thinking
loopy like you like like as though I'm
sick but um no she is okay thank God
she's on an amazing medication that
actually Shrunk the tumor in half in 6
months I mean it's just unbelievable she
didn't even have to do chemo so wow yeah
well good for your mom so
happy so
happy you I did your father and your
father passed away and then your mother
right after right that's hard very hard
did you and you were really close with
your mom I heard so like did did she
ever leave you with any advice that you
still just keep around with you well my
mom I was I call and complain all the
time about everything this person cut me
off this person did this she always said
to me you don't know what you you don't
know what your neighbor is going through
and I keep saying my neighbor are rich
they're okay they
fine you don't know what your neighbor
are going through like you what she
meant is like you never know the next
person in the Subway or out you know
what they're going through like nobody
walk around with their information right
yeah so she's just like say you know you
need to be grateful for whatever you
have right so she passed away December
2012 and I remember 10 days after losing
her I went to to a job in Copenhagen and
I already got the job before and I
didn't want to cancel cuz she wouldn't
want me to cancel so I went to do the
job but I told my agent don't tell them
that I um I lost my mom I'm going there
in and out and I'm coming out yeah and
it's easier if you don't have to address
it right then so I got there in the
morning and the lady was on her computer
and she says oh I had such a not long
long long day um night I was shopping
and my head I'm like you complain about
shopping and she said that her friend um
oh my God her friend dad her friend
husband just got killed by she went he
went for a run and a car hit him and
they have three kids and the oldest is
10 years old and so the her friend can
doesn't even recognize where she is and
she doesn't want the kids to go without
Christmas oh my God that's why she was
doing the shpp you were thinking like oh
shopping's hard but then you don't
really know the whole story behind it
and that day earlier before I leave my
hotel and I never put TV on the TV was
on it was Obama and TV crying about the
sanday Sunday hook and he was crying
talking about it and just the fact that
these women put shoes of their kids take
them to school and they getting a call
come pick up your Dead's like kids and
for me I lost my mom when I was older I
had a job like I was already older yeah
oh this is what she meant you don't know
what your neighbors are going through
right because crying yeah I am too and
that's why I keep telling people just be
good to your parents she told me that
yeah I was in a fight with my my mom
actually before all this happened and
she's like you don't understand don't do
this don't do this don't do this like in
life like we don't know we're going to
die like that's is like a Universe rule
we all know that's going to happen right
so what is what is the problem like if
if we know we're going to die then why
we we're so hurt when they're gone it's
because what we didn't say yesterday
yeah you know it's what they don't know
what we think of them right just tell
people you love them and let don't let
your ego get the best of you yeah we
take it for granted that there is a
tomorrow yeah guys we're so fragile look
what is the world is going on right now
just yeah just be a good person and if
you want to tell someone you tell them
you but
then it but it doesn't have to go to
violence yeah that's sit there yeah yeah
yeah well let's take a quick break
episodes of season 14 of The Real
Housewives of New York City if it's
anything like just this convers it's
going to be so intense I love it um but
they are now streaming on peacock y'all
got to go check that
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home